200 años después de su muerte la huella
de napoleón sigue vigente en francia en
américa latina' su influencia fue
determinante en la creación del sistema
jurídico tras los procesos
independentistas del siglo 19 el código
civil- napoleónico proporciona un texto
que fue imitado primero en haití y
después en el actual estado de luciana
para terminar llegando al resto de
latinoamérica la influencia francesa
sigue siendo enorme en todo lo que tiene
que ver con el derecho privado e incluso
el derecho público entre los principales
juristas latinoamericanos surgieron las
figuras de andrés bello en 1855 y
dalmacio vélez en argentina
en 1869 su impulso respondió a una forma
de atraer extranjeros al país con el
objetivo de que sintieran que su
lenguaje jurídico continuaba siendo el
mismo
sin embargo los tiempos fueron cambiando
primero en 1968 y después en 2015 los
argentinos modificaron su código las
reivindicaciones por los derechos
sociales y el constitucionalismo habían
llegado a américa latina' las reglas de
familia han cambiado muchísimo
para dar un ejemplo las reglas sobre
divorcio vincular han cambiado y de
hecho durante muchos años en argentina
las familias
las parejas si bien podían divorciarse
no podían volver a casarse en el momento
actual cada vez más estados de
latinoamérica se plantean renovar sus
códigos civiles en chile- el proceso
constituyente que vive el país va
acompañado de una discusión sobre un
nuevo texto
claudia iriarte profesora de derecho en
la universidad de chile es una de las
mujeres que forma parte del grupo de
expertas que estudian un nuevo código
civil con enfoque de género debe la
constitución recoger no sólo estos
cambios propuestos en código civil sino
un cambio más sustancial que significa
garantizar la condición de su pleno
sujeto un código civil nuevo adaptado a
los tiempos que sin embargo mantiene su
esencia basada en la longeva sombra de
napoleón